l'objectif de la négociation qui aura
lieu à Montréal c'est d'établir un cadre
décennal c'est pour les 10 années qui
viennent et qui va succéder à ce qu'on a
appelé les objectifs d'eishi objectif
d'eishi qui a mentionné Renan Dantec et
qui n'ont pas été atteints pour des tas
de raisons sur lequel peut-être on
reviendra
des facto depuis 2010 adoption des
objectifs d'eishi on a une effectivement
une dégradation de la biodiversité dans
le monde avec un état alarmant sur
lequel je ne reviendrai pas vous avez
entendu les chiffres je suis sûr que
vous avez lu tous les rapports et
certainement
tous les vous avez écouté aussi tout ce
qui a été dit très y compris très
récemment à travers un rapport de VVF
sur l'état de la biodiversité un point
important c'est effectivement d'avoir
bien conscience des cinq causes de la
dégradation de la biodiversité parce
qu'en réalité c'est bien ça qui va
falloir s'attaquer à travers ce cadre le
changement
des terres et des mers en réalité c'est
à la fois l'emprise de l'agriculture et
de l'urbanisation essentiellement la
surexploitation des espèces sauvages là
l'emblème je dirais et le plus évident
c'est la surpêche
[Musique]
le changement climatique dont on voit
que l'impact sur la biodiversité de plus
en plus importante puisque par
définition lorsqu'il y a du stress
hydrique qu'on a une modification des
écosystèmes la pollution chimique et les
espèces exotiques envahissantes qui
deviennent un vrai sujet en termes de
dégradation de la biodiversité